[inaudible]
joining me today as a writer and activist and the founder of theory of
enchantment.com Chloe,
Valerie,
welcome to the Rubin report.
Thank you for having me.
I'm very happy to have you here because you are one of,
I don't know,
I'd say 12 people online that don't make me completely insane.
Like I look at your Twitter feed and I'm like,
oh,
there's someone with a brain that's actually not completely insane.
Thanks.
Yeah.
That's the highest compliment I can give.
Anyway.
So actually we met a couple of months ago in September at a Jordan Peterson
event.
Would you say that was the best white supremacist event you were ever at all?
Excellent.
Yeah.
That was terrifying.
Before we get into your history and everything else and you're doing,
you're doing truly so much great work.
What do you make of the Peterson phenomenon?
Because so many of my guests I'm finding are coming to shows and it's like,
it's pretty cool.
I understand Jordan Peterson,
like fundamentally I understand what he's doing.
Um,
I think that,
I think that he is compelling to many people because in many cases he's a
storyteller.
He's a great storyteller.
And what he can do is he can distill lessons from stories,
stories found in pop culture stories that are history and,
and derive lessons that you can apply to your life.
And I think that anyone who can do that will be compelling because they can
actually better your life.
And I think that's the secret as to why he's so popular.
And also I've noticed that he's,
I think he's becoming more mainstream.
It's like he's becoming more acceptable into,
in mainstream society.
Which is it,
which is a positive trend.
Like seeing him being interviewed on Doctor Oz,
for example.
It was like a moment,
I think of him inching closer and closer to the mainstream.
What's that phrase?
First they ignore you,
then they mock you right?
Then they want to be you in that version of it.
All right.
We'll speak in the stories.
Tell me a little bit about your story.
Who the hell are you?
Oh,
yes,
I am Chloe.
I'm from New Orleans originally born and raised.
Um,
my story,
I guess it's an interesting one.
I was born and raised in a very atypical Christian family.
Atypical in the sense that I grew up as a Christian observing Shabbat.
Yeah.
So what is that?
What is that?
So the way I like to tell him is,
you know,
have you heard of seven day Adventist?
So it's like seven day Adventist,
but on steroids essentially.
That's how I grew up.
Um,
so seven day Adventists,
to my understanding,
they keep Shabbat,
that's why they call them the seventh day.
So they'd go to church on Saturday instead of Sunday.
So we did that also,
but we also did things like we observed Yom Kippur and Rosh Hashanah and all the
Jewish holy days.
And we also kept kosher style.
So I don't eat pork or shellfish.
And that was an interesting upbringing.
I have two funny stories to tell you.
Um,
the first is about Yom Kippor.
Yeah.
So as I'm sure you know,
and the Jews in the Jewish tradition once or twice,
right?
Right.
Yeah.
So can you tell me what age one begins?
Fasting for Yom Kippor.
Okay.
Well there's an obvious answer here that obviously can't be the right answer,
but I would assume 13.
Oh,
okay.
Y'All,
yeah,
you're pulling the trigger.
Yeah.
Okay.
Um,
well my parents didn't have their binnacle text to advise them on like what age
they should make their kids start fasting and soul.
For some reason they decided that five years old was a good time to,
so I've been fast and free Yom Kippor since I was five,
so yeah.
You're an old pro now.
Yes,
yes.
Um,
so that's like one quick story of how I grew up in the,
my father introduced me to the writings of Leon Uris when I was 15 years old.
So he was a really same as Jewish author who wrote a lot about the
reestablishment of the state of Israel.
He wrote books like exodus and Qbe seven and millet 18 and I read all these
books throughout high school and was part of the Hebrew Culture Club in high
school.
Went to a very egalitarian high school in New Orleans.
Um,
so this is sort of my introduction to the world of Jewish culture,
but also Israel in a contemporary sense.
And then I attended the University of New Orleans where I initially majored in
film,
but then switch majors to international studies in 2012
graduated magna cum laude.
Yes.
I had to think about it.
Um,
but the reason why I switched majors with,
because antisemitism was resurfacing in Europe,
in France in particular.
Yeah.
So this is about what,
seven,
eight years?
This is 2012.
Yeah.
So,
and I wanted to get involved in the Israel space,
so that's why I switched majors.
And then I started a student Pro Israel organization on campus.
Um,
did Israel advocacy for three and a half years.
Realize that we didn't know what we were doing,
but I learned a lot from that experience.
Um,
and that was my college experience.
Yeah.
Okay.
So we're going to get to obviously a lot of the advocacy work that you do and
some of the things that you've written and all that,
but just a little bit more on the,
on the growing up part because there's something really fascinating there.
It's like it's sort of for you it's like,
oh well this is how I grew up.
You kind of [inaudible] but it sounds for other people it's like,
wait a minute.
So she's Christian,
but with celebrating all these Jewish holidays,
like how,
how was that explained to you as a child or was it explained?
Yeah,
that's your choice.
Like it was like the explanation was this is how Jesus and the disciples
observed,
so we're going to observe in this way.
That was like the basic explanation and then like just growing up,
you know,
you're conditioned to do these things and so it just becomes rote and becomes
like basic.
But like you were saying,
it doesn't make sense to a lot of people looking from the outside in.
So yeah.
Okay.
So college you started realizing that,
that the things that you had grown up around,
that something was sort of under assault?
Yeah.
Is that fair to say?
Yeah,
I think,
yeah,
and I think that because,
um,
you know,
antisemitism is fundamentally like dehumanization of Jews.
And because I had grown up with such a,
not just like a love for the Jewish people,
but in awareness of Jewish culture,
like to a certain extent,
I've,
my identity was defined by Jewish culture or adjacent to Jewish culture.
So I think in that sense it did feel like something,
a part of me was under attack.
So that was probably a huge catalyst for getting involved.
What did the,
like your Jewish friends about this girl that you know,
doesn't stereotypically looked Jewish,
which is a ridiculous thing to say,
of course,
because there are black Jews and Tino Jews and Chinese Jews and everything else.
Um,
did your friends think like,
what is this
in college or in college growing up,
whatever it is,
growing up,
I don't,
I don't know if they,
if they thought any different,
I don't remember.
I just remember that the Jewish kids and myself were not in school during Rosh
Hashana.
We're just out of,
we were just acting at the same time.
I'm in college.
I just made all my Friday.
Good.
If you want a couple extra days off,
it's very good.
They're good.
I mean,
I didn't even talk about,
so you could,
that's a whole nother story.
But in college,
my friend,
I just made my friends join my club so they,
like,
I just made them like there was no like,
oh,
this is,
it was just who I was and like a part of,
you know,
my life.
Yeah.
So it seems to me that right now,
I guess campus antisemitism is sort of running rampant.
I think it has a lot to do with bds and we can talk about that and more.
But what,
what were you actually seeing back then that were the marker?
Yeah,
I mean back then,
so there wasn't a lot of,
there wasn't like systemic antisemitism at the University of New Orleans.
Um,
or for example at Tulane where I did a lot of,
uh,
pro Israel stuff also.
Um,
but actually what I discovered was though there was antisemitism on certain
campuses or in hotbed campuses like Columbia and UC Irvine.
And we've heard about all of these different campuses where there,
you know,
problems.
The larger issue was that we in the community were confusing two different
things.
We were confusing two very important questions with each other.
The first question was,
how do you combat antisemitism?
Which is a novel question,
a good question,
a question that got me involved,
uh,
with the question of how do you actually get people to fall in love with
Israelis?
And we were confusing those two questions.
And as a result,
we were coming.
We were,
we were shaping the basis of our advocacy around,
uh,
the wrong assumption.
So like the first question,
how do you fight antisemitism is essentially a question of how do you get people
to stop hating?
But the second question,
how do you get people to fall in love with Israelis?
There's really,
society is a question of how do you get people to start loving,
which is a totally different question.
And we,
we,
and I say like collectively,
the peripheral community in America hadn't figured that out.
And so as a result,
we were doing pro Israel advocacy.
We were putting together projects within the realm of pro Israel advocacy.
That didn't make sense.
Yeah.
And that was the larger trend that I observed that I witnessed when I was in
college.
All right.
So let's do both of those.
So first,
how do you deal with disassembling antisemitism?
We're just hatred.
Yeah.
Well I think so.
I think they're interconnected,
connected on some level.
I think,
um,
it's not just enough to,
to continue to tell people to stop painting.
Obviously that's important,
but you also have to create a framework and create,
um,
sort of like a,
uh,
a collection of lessons,
if you will,
on how to start loving on how to love,
if you will.
Um,
and I,
so,
so I think that that actually ends up combating antisemitism and combating all
forms of hatred.
If you actually build out a framework or try to teach people how to love,
do you think there's something unique about hating Jews that's a little bit
different than hating other people?
Like sort of partly of a history,
a historical reason?
Yeah,
because it's goes back forever basically.
Okay.
But also that I find right now,
I mean most of the people that hate me or are on the left,
let's say.
Right.
Um,
so I get a relentless amount of hate from them and I don't,
I don't get a lot of hate from the right,
but every now and again when I get a hate hatred from the right,
it's,
Oh,
you do blah,
blah,
that kind of thing.
Yeah.
It's,
in my case,
it's very disproportionate on one side that probably has more to do with my
politics right now.
But I do think it's interesting that it sort of,
it is that horseshoe theory where the people on the fringes both end up hating
you for identity.
Right.
Uh,
that's a good question.
Do I think antisemitism is like uniquely a problem or uniquely different?
I mean,
if you were to look at intersectionality,
for example,
which is this,
I was hoping we'd get to it.
Yeah.
My favorite talk.
Yeah,
let's do it.
Um,
can you explain?
Let's,
let's,
let's steal man,
intersectionality.
Give me,
give me what the,
the person out there that's the believer in intersectionality.
What,
how,
what,
what would they tell you intersectionality is before we knock it down,
right?
I think I can still man it,
I mean,
I,
I'd say that intersectionality makes three claims,
one of which is true.
Um,
the first claim that it makes is that you can,
you can experience intersecting forms of oppression.
So I,
as both a woman and a person of color can experience forms of oppression by
virtues of those categories to which I belong.
And they can interest,
intersect and interact with each other in new ways.
And I think that's the record.
I'd been conducting this interview as if you were a white man.
Oh,
thank you.
I just want to be clear clinical sign out there.
Thank you so much.
It's such a relief.
Okay.
But you've got these,
you've got these two immutable characteristics.
Basically that right could intertwine based in their outsider characteristics.
That's it.
So like a person,
a man could be sexist toward me or a white person can be racist to me.
Right.
And then,
and then both of those types of discriminations or prejudices can interact in
different ways,
which I think is a basically true statement.
Right.
Okay.
Um,
so that is the extent to which
I can still manage the sectionality.
Okay.
Now give me now give me the nod.
Right.
Um,
the not so true.
Actually I would say dangerously false claims of intersectionality.
One is that the primary motivator a bit behind all human interaction is power.
And by power they mean like that power in order to oppress.
Um,
so I could be having a disagreement,
political disagreement with you in good faith.
Um,
but according to the intersection of lists,
it doesn't matter because you have white skin and I have brown skin.
And so you,
by virtue of the category that you exist and you are trying to impress me.
Right?
And in this case,
my gayness would fall below the importance of say my white skin is actually an
intersection on the scale of intersectionality,
right?
Jewishness is completely sort of thrown out,
which I think is related to the Israel thing.
Which one?
Definitely like hierarchies of what know,
like virtues and stuff like that or lack thereof in your case.
Yeah.
Uh,
I'm just me,
but can I tell you?
So that's the,
that's the first,
uh,
dangerous claim that it makes.
And then the second conclusion,
I guess you would say to which it comes is a conclusion of ratio.
Essential Ism.
So what that means is you could take any human basic human behavior,
let's say feeling entitled,
right?
So my friend could have a new iPhone x and for some reason like I don't have the
money to buy the iPhone x,
but I want the iPhone x,
whatever I'm coveting,
right?
Yeah.
This iPhone x if you will.
So I feel a sense of entitlement to it,
right?
So any human being can feel the sense of entitlement,
That's my point.
But the intersectionalists will,
will claim that entitlement,
like a priori is the white man's thing.
So they will refer to entitlements as white male entitlement as if the only type
of human being,
um,
that can feel or express a behavior of entitlement is a white male.
Um,
and so in doing that,
they are,
uh,
racially essentially rising people.
They are taking human behaviors and turning them into essential characteristics
of people that belong to one category.
So as somebody that comes from a unique religious perspective,
yeah.
What do you make of the religious nature of the people that buy into this
ideology?
That's a good question.
I mean it's,
it's like,
like many religions,
it is all encompassing.
Um,
like money will certainly like certain,
let's say a mainstream forms of Christianity.
It sort of preaches this born again type mentality where you become woke.
Right?
Which is just another word for enlighten.
That's what they do by knowing
no,
but like there's the parallel.
Well,
they're like,
you've become,
well,
you got born again,
you become,
um,
the problem,
one of the many problems is that there is no salvation.
There's no redemption in this religion.
Um,
you get Brownie points,
virtue points if you are a,
if you belong to certain categories,
like if you're a person of color,
if you're a woman,
et Cetera,
and you get less points if you're white,
if you're male,
if you're straight,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
Um,
and what this does is it has a caricaturing effect on,
on human beings,
um,
where people are reduced to characatures.
Uh,
it creates this effect where the people who are intersectionalists and Hobo who
believe in this theory,
um,
are sort of incapable of dealing with nuance and dealing with depth and human
complexity,
which is sad,
not just for the people that they're attacking,
but for themselves.
Do you think it's an overstep to call it the new type of racism?
Because I'm really coming around to that really hedging.
Yeah.
Like I'm like right there on that.
I've said it once or twice.
I don't really like saying it cause I don't,
I don't want to start using the tactics,
which I hate so much.
Right.
Of course.
I don't want to do that.
But,
uh,
I don't know if you saw my,
my episode with her in August,
I had Catherine verbal Singh,
who's a wonderful teacher at mckayla school in the UK.
Okay.
And she flat out and she's a brown skin and you know the whole thing.
Yeah.
But she doesn't buy into any of this nonsense.
And she was adamant in saying this is the new racism and we must call it that.
And I agree with the heart of the center man.
And I just adore her.
And that was,
I spoke in school a couple weeks ago,
but,
but I'm a little leery of why are you leery of it?
Because I don't want to fall into the same trap that they've come in where every
time I hear one of their arguments,
the idea would be that I could just turn to them and be like,
well,
you're the new racist.
You know what I mean?
Where cause it's just right and shut it down.
It's so easy and lazy and the rest of it.
So I don't see,
I don't want to do that.
And yet if I see the way the world is now,
where I see real,
true racism coming from,
it's almost exclusively coming from these people.
I'm not saying that there aren't some white nationalists.
There are some,
they have no power.
Nobody cares about them.
They're mocked and they're,
they're actually propped up by the media to make it seem like they're running
the world.
Yeah.
But where I see true racism coming from these days and a true hatred based on
immutable characteristics is this set of intersectional woke people.
Yeah.
I just don't want to be,
I just don't want to be
that.
Right,
right.
That's a very good and deep question.
I think that for my purposes,
I don't just want to like,
I want to criticize in a,
in a meaningful way.
So I would have to ask the question while I get people who believe in
intersectionalists theory to change or convinced them to change simply by
calling them racist.
Probably not.
They,
it's not,
when they call all these people on the right,
they call basic conservatives or libertarians races.
It's not like they're coming around.
So it's only been like,
Oh yes,
you're right.
I should just be an intersectional.
I am woke born
again.
No,
it doesn't work.
There's work though.
Yeah.
So,
so I think I would rather challenge people who believe in this theory on their
own terms.
Um,
okay.
Do you get a unique credit to do that because of your,
so how does that,
how does that,
how does that work that you could almost use their own crappy thing against him
in a bizarre way,
even though you don't believe in it?
That there's a unique power there I suppose.
But I think
what I do is I couldn't say depth,
meaning I think I am an example of human complexity.
So on the surface level,
I am using their own hierarchy.
A virtuous people are virtuous types against them.
But at the same time I think I'm,
I'm showing them what that human complexity actually exists because I disagree
with them.
So it's like a cognitive dissonance thing that they have to figure out.
Um,
but I'm more interested in peep in and trying to challenge people who believe in
this,
especially young people would say this is on the college campuses and such to
become better people.
Um,
and I have to,
in order to do that,
I have to criticize them in a way that actually speaks to their potential to be
better people.
Um,
and um,
like I said,
I'm not going to accomplish that by calling them racist.
But what I can do is try to,
I can try to,
for example,
point them to,
I think authors and people in literature for example,
who they highly esteem,
um,
whose work they don't quite yet realize is not intersection.
Yeah.
So who,
who might that be?
Right.
Maya Angelo for example.
Um,
I think that there is a very stark contrast between like Ta-nehisi coats and my
Angelo,
the very first poets I was forced to memorize as a child was my Angelo.
And so like I feel like I,
I carry her spirit with me.
Um,
and the way she talks about human complexity and the way she talks about how no
bling the human spirit is at is in many ways a contrast to intersectionalists
theory.
Um,
she famously one time said that Shakespeare must've been a black woman because
the,
and the,
because it's like one of his sonnets.
She,
she felt so closely and intimately connected to in the struggles that she was
going,
going through as a child.
And her point was that,
um,
all of this literature,
uh,
if it,
even if it comes from like,
let's say the dead white male,
right,
um,
was written for all of you,
for each of you,
and you can see yourself in that,
in the stories that these great writers create it.
And that's the point.
That's what makes them great writers,
is the fact that you can see yourself in them.
So I would point people toward,
especially her work because they typically and generally esteem her and they
consider her to be,
um,
an icon.
And I think she was an icon.
Um,
but other than that,
I can use that to actually teach them,
well,
here's an alternative way of thinking actually,
and what you're learning in your poststructuralist class about like human life
and human affairs isn't necessarily,
um,
true when it isn't.
It isn't the only thing out there.
What do you make of the fact that it seems like so many young people are going
to college so ill to deal with the world as it is that they become so religious
in nature when it comes to this stuff?
Like if they had been given better tools,
perhaps some of the things that Jordan Peterson's talking about that they could
go into school and be challenged and be okay with it as opposed to going in and
converting ca,
I guess that's a parent problem.
It's the parents and the parents.
Yeah.
Um,
yeah.
I mean I think,
I think it's a question of upbringing,
obviously.
Um,
but I also think,
I think that maybe it signifies that students are searching for meaning.
I mean,
students are searching for meaning.
I was searching for meaning in college,
you know,
um,
we're searching for meaning all of our lives.
Right.
And then what does it say that that the only thing that seeming seemingly off
there that's giving them meaning at least within the college context is
intersectionalists theory.
I mean like surely we as a society can do better than that,
but I think that Jordan Peterson represents is this contrast because he is
getting a lot of fame and popular.
He is considered to be popular amongst some people,
many people in college probably.
So I think that in that sense,
um,
maybe they're not being as converted as,
as much as,
as much as a it seems they are.
Yeah.
Maybe there is a,
there is a battle of ideas of the hearts and minds of these students.
So that's a good thing.
Well,
there's,
I mean there's definitely statistical evidence that that's true,
right?
There was that study that came out a couple of months ago that basically only 8%
of young people actually are these hysterical shrieking intersection list.
But because they're so loud,
they're just silencing and majority.
So that's encouraging.
Well,
the sun,
that means it's our fault because,
right.
Well that's what I always say.
If people,
every event I go to and not being loud enough really.
Well that's the funny thing is like every,
literally every event I go to from the Peterson event that you were out in long
island to all it too.
When I do standup gigs,
whatever it is,
people come up to me everywhere they go,
what can I do?
What can I do?
Right?
And the only thing that I can come up with that has any meaning whatsoever is
start speaking,
right?
Like you live in the freest society in the history of the world and you're
afraid to say what you think,
how would you be one of the bad plays?
Yeah.
And also like with social media,
we all have our own media companies now.
Like anything is possible.
Yeah.
So yeah,
I think,
I think we need to start speaking more,
but I also think we need to,
like I said earlier,
we need to emphasize like it's not enough to tell people how to stop hating.
We also have to teach them how to start loving.
And I think that that's something that needs to be developed further also.
All right,
so let's put the start loving part on hold for a minute.
Cause that seems like a good ending point for me.
So let's put that to the end.
Okay.
Yeah,
I've noticed you,
you've been pretty critical about what's going on in the women's March and
we're,
I think we're starting to see,
which I think is positive that this intersectional sort of hierarchy or my
monster I think is a better word.
They can't hold very long.
And I think we're seeing the evidence of that now.
Can you explain a little bit of why that is?
Have you seen the article that came out yesterday and tablet about the women's
March?
I've had a crazy couple of days here,
so,
yeah.
So all this time,
you know,
we had this suspicion that the leaders in the women's march,
including Tamika Mallory,
Linda Sarsour and Carmen Perez,
we're sort of like pretty like anti-semite antisemetic like Hob knobbing with
Farah Khan and uh,
posting very positive remarks about Farah Khan on their social media platforms.
And right
when you say we,
you mean like us and the other,
sorry.
Yes,
I should click whatever you want to call that subset of people,
not,
not what mainstream portrays them to.
Sure.
So I say that this has been a concern in the Jewish community by and large for a
very long time.
Like the majority of Jews in this country are pro Israel,
right?
And so the w so collectively the pro Israel community has had a creeping
suspicion about these women's intentions when it count,
when they came to allowing Jews to march or like telling you to have a safe
place to march or even a space to march and the women's March.
And I'm,
I'm actually part of a organization called Zionists,
which tries to give us space to progressive Jewish women to March in these
women,
in these women's marches.
Even though Linda Sarsour was shouting at them,
you,
there's no room for you here,
right?
Yeah.
Um,
so the idea is like,
oh,
you're not going to give us a table.
We'll build our own table.
And what boards interesting is that yesterday this bombshell report came out and
tell the magazine and our worst suspicions were confirmed.
Um,
I did see a little bit,
it's actually about the security and everything.
Yeah.
So go ahead.
So apparently I'll say allegedly,
allegedly at the very first meeting with these women,
um,
who were being added to as,
I guess it's cold tears to the women's march,
there was,
there were antisemitic statements made about Jews.
Um,
um,
and consistently throughout their time as cochairs.
Um,
there was a legend,
they have allegedly been hiring a security folks from the nation of Islam,
fair constellations,
nation of Islam.
For those of you who may be watching who don't know,
Farah Khan has famously,
uh,
referred to or infamously referred to Jews as termites.
I mean,
he's a notorious anti Semite.
Yeah.
So it turns out things on Twitter.
No problem.
Yeah.
You can check them out.
Twitter right down below.
Right,
exactly.
Yeah.
So these women have been hiring
security guards and nation of Islam to do their security detail at the women's
March.
And so it's a really bombshell report.
I encourage your viewers to read it,
but
yeah,
we actually will link to it.
Okay.
Not to far.
Again,
we'll put a link to the art.
Yeah.
And it is like a,
it,
it's,
it's a,
it's a crazy moment.
So,
so does this seem like it's obvious to you in a way?
Like,
it sort of seems obvious to me that two,
three years ago there were bunch of us,
I think sort of old school,
decent liberals that were like this thing,
this marriage in held between the women's March and Sarsour like right,
this thing can't hold,
of course this is going to happen.
Right?
So like I think there's a little bit of,
like I told you,
so there,
for some of us,
you know,
I'm going,
I posted this on my Facebook yesterday and I definitely got some of that.
So,
so
what did,
that doesn't make me feel any better.
Right though.
It's not like you're like,
all right,
Haha.
See those predominantly.
Right,
right,
right.
I mean,
I guess one just hope that people who are leaders would have the integrity and
responsibility and introspection to not do this.
So,
so what do you think has to happen then for the woman's march to move forward
with whatever the goodness of that is?
Yeah,
right.
I think,
well,
we,
for example,
I decided I'm not marching in the women in the,
in any march affiliated with the women's March Inc,
which is,
which is the organization that those women sit on the board of.
Um,
so I'm just not going to,
and there are other marches there,
there are other individual marches that have actually cut ties with women's
march ink that people can still march with if they feel so inclined.
But as far as that particular organization a is considered,
I'm that I'm not marching with them anymore.
So is the inherent problem of sort of just collectivism as a,
as a ideology that to see a woman's march is inherently sort of ridiculous
because,
well,
because everyone's for when it's a very,
as Jordan would say,
it's a low resolution argument.
Everyone would say that you're for women,
right?
Like no one's not for women or for women to be equal,
not nobody,
but by and large,
any sane member of society is not for women to be equal in a Western society at
least.
Yeah.
Um,
but when you say you're for women,
what you're always going to do is exclude the minority women.
So in this case,
forget,
forget skin color even,
although this is a,
this is a minority skin color,
I suppose the women's march organizers,
they're not for Nikki Haley,
there not for a strong conservative woman who happens to have brown skin,
but we've been forgetting her skin color.
They're not for Sarah Huckabee Sanders there.
They're not for any woman that doesn't believe in the ideology.
So you're saying you're for women,
you mean that women who behave
right.
That's an interesting retort.
Um,
I think,
I think I slightly disagree with,
with the,
if you specify the demographics that you are marching on behalf than you are,
um,
necessarily not including other,
other people in that category.
It happens to be the case.
Well,
I will tell you maybe it's de facto and maybe not intended like the function of
it.
Ultimately,
I think,
yeah,
I
think,
I don't think there's anything wrong with,
with outlining like on whose behalf you're marching.
Um,
I do take your point that,
that,
uh,
but I think that this,
this has been true of women's marches,
if you will,
throughout,
throughout the,
like since the suffrage movement,
like even within the stuff,
the,
the women's suffrage movement,
there was,
there was a lot of,
there were a lot of tensions because for example,
um,
who was the thing?
Who's the most famous one?
Uh,
Susan VSA.
Yes.
Okay.
So there was a dispute between Susan B.
Anthony,
if I have my facts correct fact check me on this one.
There's a dispute.
Oh,
don't worry.
This is youtube bell.
Factcheck yeah.
There a dispute between Susan B.
Anthony and another woman whose name of course I forget at this moment.
Um,
and the reason was that Susan B.
Anthony was actually willing to Hob knob with people who are racist,
um,
in order to,
to get the vote passed.
Um,
and this other woman who had,
who was one of the founders of the suffragists moment had this falling out with
her because she was like,
you cannot associate with,
you know,
these people who are trying to to undermine on,
I'll go demographic in the country.
And so I say all that to say that I think that there will always be these
tensions within these mass movements,
especially if if you read this article that came out and tell the magazine,
especially if from the,
especially if you are a rooted in a intersectionalists framework,
I think that that's the issue.
I think that you,
you might be able to see Nikki Haley and um,
some of the other women you mentioned,
if it wasn't actually rooted in intersectionality.
On the other hand,
the woman's march is a progressive,
is a self proclaimed,
progressive,
um,
organization,
progressive movement.
And so by virtue of that,
they're not going to include Republican.
Right?
So I guess that's it.
So the name is a bit of a misnomer.
So that's what it is,
I think.
Right.
I would argue that being for progressivism as it stands in 2018 is not being for
women.
So I guess it's a little bit of that.
And so I think that if you were to,
if you were to come across the progressive march like a decade ago,
yeah,
sure.
Look very different from how it looks now.
So that's actually a perfect segue.
How is this all connected to whatever is going on with feminism right now?
Do you think,
Oh,
do you consider yourself a feminist?
I know it's a,
it's a label that people are sort of scared of now.
They either embrace it and they're not sure why are they're very scared of it
or,
yeah,
I don't really have this like knee jerk viscerally like self discussed where the
term feminism as I,
as I,
I feel like maybe people certainly on the right are increasingly having that,
that reaction.
And I think I understand why,
like if,
if you,
if third wave feminism is rooted in intersectionality than like blegh I believe
in feminism as a basic like idea,
you know,
um,
I love the,
I love the work of Camille Paglia so,
so to that extent,
I'm deaf.
She's been fighting this for a long time.
Uh,
but I think like basic,
if you believe in like equality for women and basic egalitarianism,
to the extent that that is feminism,
I'm a feminist.
I don't,
I don't need to like adopt all the other frameworks at their way.
Feminism is adopting now to consider myself a feminist,
I'd say.
Yeah.
So let's just back up slightly to what you were saying about these competing
sort of methods and how people do things.
So Susan B,
Anthony was willing to talk to some people.
This other woman was,
and I mean we've seen this in all sorts of movements.
Martin Luther King,
yeah.
Behaved a certain way.
Talk to certain people.
Malcolm X had a different view of it.
So you view that as sort of a necessary,
uh,
sort of push and pull on how a movement is built?
Well,
I,
yeah,
I mean I think,
I think that,
that whether I believe in it or not,
that is what that is.
How movements are bill.
Um,
I think especially if you look at the Martin Luther King versus Malcolm x
dichotomy,
um,
it's much more interesting because I was actually just talking to a friend of
bosses.
I don't think people realize how difficult it was in the 60s to buy into and
practice Dr King's philosophy.
Like we take it for granted in 2018
even though a lot of people don't do it now in a warm way.
Right?
Yes.
But I think that makes sense.
Cause we're ironically privileged.
I'm exposed to it.
Um,
that's a good title for a book.
Ironically privileged.
Yeah.
Um,
but people don't realize that these,
these,
these guys were training themselves not to fight back when they were being,
when,
when they were having,
you know,
like condiments poured on them and diners like that.
It's hard.
It's a to,
to route your belief in the idea that I'm not going to fight back because these
white people were made in the image of God is a profoundly crazy belief.
And my crazy,
I mean like groundbreaking,
incredibly difficult to actually put into practice,
right?
Novel,
beautiful.
And I so I,
so I think that has to be understood when we contrast or juxtapose Malcolm x
with Dr. King.
I think that if you were to read Malcolm x's autobiography,
um,
and what happened to him and,
and this is important because people need to understand why the nation of Islam
has a cert to a certain extent and to a certain degree of hold in the black
community,
the nation of Islam at the time that Malcolm x was alive was literally taking
young black men who at this point,
for example in Harlem,
we're addicts were junkies and turning them into men of upstanding society,
right?
And so in order to,
in order to counter the toxic and deleterious effects of the nation of Islam,
we have to reckon and we'd have to be willing to accept and acknowledge that
fact,
right?
The problem is that that process of empowerment was also deeply rooted in a very
toxic ideology.
Um,
namely hating white people and by hating white people,
let me be very clear because I feel like people don't know the extent to which
the nation of Islam is crazy when it comes to this issue.
Bring it,
the nation of Islam believes that white people are actually like,
like not fully evolved like that they are actually,
um,
subhuman and that during the day
time or you're talking to a termite over here.
Exactly.
Yeah.
Like,
but like actually and,
and that during the time of the,
I don't know,
what would you call it?
Messianic age.
That's like why people will be destroyed and people of color will take their
proper place,
um,
in the hierarchy of,
I don't know,
the great circle of life.
So it's not,
it's not some,
like,
it's not just simply,
oh,
you,
you were very,
like,
people who were white were historically very harmful toward black people.
And so that's why we don't like them.
No,
no,
no.
It's an entire like,
like ideology rooted in.
I'm literally thinking why people are subhuman and it's interesting cause
people,
people will on the one hand,
but like in the,
in on the scene at the same time people will praise Malcolm x and presentation
of Islam without even recognizing that Malcolm x was killed by the nation of
Islam,
um,
disavowed the nation of Islam.
But at the time he went to Mecca,
right and came back.
Um,
and they're not willing to wrestle with,
with the nuances of,
of that particular movement seriously.
But I still have that
where you recognize the power of that obviously.
Right?
Sure.
Hour of,
sort of just as an easy answer.
Yes.
That's what it is.
This is easy.
It's certain,
right.
And it's very difficult for people to live with uncertainty,
which I think is something that the right needs to recognize any scrapple with
when it is rightfully criticizing things like intersectionality,
right.
There is an attraction in being certain,
right?
Because if you have to deal with uncertainty,
if you have to accept uncertainty as a factor of life,
as very difficult,
we have like fight or flight brains.
Yeah.
Right.
We're not,
we're not evolved to deal with uncertainty on some level or to be comfortable
with uncertainty.
And yet it's almost the only certainty.
Right,
right.
Paradoxically.
Yeah.
Yes,
yes.
But that is,
that I think also speaks to why intersectionality is so attractive because it
gives people a way to anchor their insecurities into something that is
steadfast.
So when you see people using some of the language that the intersection lists or
the woe crew buy into.
So for example,
a couple of weeks ago,
GML Hill formula of ESPN,
now the Atlantic.
Yeah.
She tweeted out the Jordan Peterson's a white supremacist and massaging it.
So why do you know it gets 20,000 retweets or sounding right?
Wasn't he just,
uh,
speaking to the Seattle Seahawks?
Yeah.
Okay.
This is what I meant by the way when I said mainstream,
like that's awesome.
Okay.
Continuous.
Yeah.
Oh Buddy,
I'm glad you brought that up because that was the genesis of the tweet,
right?
Cause it was the bout that Pete Carroll,
the coach of the Seahawks,
had let white supremacist,
misogynist Jordan Peterson talk to the team.
Then another ESPN guy picks it up,
then she tweets it out.
So of course I just invited her.
I,
you know what,
I'm on tour with the guy.
Yeah,
you're welcome to.
Yeah.
I said,
you're welcome.
I didn't even say you want to debate him.
Nothing.
I just said,
I would love to have you as a guest to the show.
Right.
And of course she doesn't respond.
But what do you make of the fact that they can lay those claims so easily and
they're rewarded for it?
So in other words,
if you were to do this on the other side,
if someone on the right was to say something like,
if you call someone that's not a white supremacist,
the whites renaissance,
that's almost as damaging socially and politically and in every other way as
possible.
Right?
Right.
But if you were someone on the right,
and you said something that sounded off slightly racially,
you get called a racist,
you get fired.
And that's it.
But,
uh,
Gml Hill,
you know,
she works at a,
the Atlantic,
no problem under David Frum who sat in that very chair and,
right.
And I think Geoffrey Goldberg's the other guy.
And it's like you can say whatever you want.
Now again,
you know,
my policy on free speech,
so I'm not denying her ability to say it.
I'm just saying you got the social PR.
Yeah,
exactly.
Social capital.
Yeah.
Um,
so what do I make it?
The social care?
Yeah.
The way that we can use it depending on,
yeah.
So I,
but I actually,
so I get what you're saying.
I think,
I think it's true,
but only to a certain extent.
And I think that the fame and rise of Jordan Peterson proves that it's only true
to a certain extent,
meaning?
Sure.
Um,
from a social perspective,
she has the freedom to make statements which are not completely thought out,
um,
which are pejorative in a way and disparaging in a way,
toward a person.
Um,
and she can do so with out,
I mean,
she obviously gets criticism,
but she can do so without consequence.
Basically,
I want a certain level,
but I would say that Jordan Peterson has a greater reach than she does.
Um,
Jordan Peterson has a greater,
um,
uh,
I would say growing fan base than she does.
And so I would question who has the more social capital,
um,
but is his social capital or it's the capital of,
of ideas.
It's the capital of good ideas.
Sure.
Sordo
yeah,
but I think that's the same thing.
So yeah,
I think that,
I think that his social capital,
um,
is accruing greater interest to continue with his metaphor and hers is and will
continue to do an impression.
Yes,
yes,
yes.
The stocks are increasing.
Yeah.
Um,
and I think that that will continue to play out.
And I think that that actually speaks to the fact that the right is partially
wrong when it talks about,
at least within the context of Jordan Peterson,
when it talks about the less social capital,
because Jordan Peterson is pumping up the Seattle Seahawks.
Right.
That's,
I don't think that's,
I mean,
I don't know if he would consider himself to be right wing,
but I don't,
I don't know if that's happened on the right in a very long time where I don't
even,
I've been traveling
with a guy for the last year,
like a hundred shows.
I don't even know that he considers himself part of the right.
I think he's vaguely right,
cause he's vaguely conservative.
But I would say he's really an old school liberal that's been smacked around by
reality.
No,
he,
but,
but in all seriousness,
he also transcends these labels.
And I think that that's his power and that his social power and I,
and that's what I,
that's what I meant when I said earlier,
I get what he's doing because he is distilling things down to their essence.
And,
and regardless of how a seemingly compelling the rhetoric of,
I don't like this guy,
Jordan Peterson,
so I'm gonna call him up.
Oh,
a white nationalist,
um,
goals far on Twitter.
His distillation and breakdown of ideas and transforming those ideas into
lessons to live your life by will almost inevitably always go,
go farther.
So I would disagree with the premise.
Yeah.
All right,
I'll take that.
I like the little silver lining that I will gladly take that.
All right,
so let's spend a little time on where you're doing most of your work now,
which is advocacy for Israel now is one of the things that as a a guy that voted
Democrat my whole life,
I can't really say I'm part of the left anymore,
but,
but a lefty my whole life until these last couple of years,
I would say one of the things I'm most disappointed by by the modern left is the
just sort of unabandoned hatred of Israel,
this six mile wide,
absurdly tiny country with no natural resources,
um,
in,
in the toughest neighborhood on earth.
Right.
Um,
that's just trying to survive basically.
Right.
Um,
but there is,
but it makes sense within the prism of everything else you've said here related
to intersectionality.
Yeah,
they sorted don't like success and Jews,
so they like minorities,
but they like minorities.
When they're oppressed,
Jews are now thought of,
is no longer oppressed.
So you automatically put them in the oppressor category.
Right now you've got a country of these people that have survived and not only
survived,
but actually thrive.
Yeah.
Although there's Arab Muslim members of the Supreme Court and everything else,
but no,
they don't really care about that.
Right.
So I don't even know what my question is other than other than like,
what is that?
It cause you all in some way,
it all just boils down to that they just hate this tiny little place that dares
survive.
Like I sort of view it that way.
Right.
That's
interesting.
I think whenever you combine the two processes of caricaturing things,
and I had another one,
it's like when you cannot occur tonight,
caricature thing,
when you turn things into a caricature,
um,
and when you,
oh,
we'll just go with that.
If your fundamental philosophy,
which I,
and I think intersectionality is,
this is Steve's caricaturing things,
then inevitably,
oh,
this is the other thing.
Caricaturing and conspiracy theories.
You put that together,
you'll get an anti to yeah.
And Inter sectionality means yes,
yes.
And it's a sectionality is,
yeah,
conspiracy theory.
Um,
and,
and also characters,
people and account cultures,
communities and characters,
societies.
And once you buy into that,
I think that you will see of course Israel was this white colonialists the
presser and Palestinians is this brown oppressed,
right?
Which is both a caricaturing and a conspiracy.
Serious.
And,
and in conspiracy theories,
you caricature people,
right?
Like that's sort of the process of how conspiracy theories work can't deal with
depth and nuance or complexity.
And so once this is your guy,
this wants,
this is your blueprint for understanding society,
then you will gravitate toward antisemitism.
Someone needs to tell him,
my brown Israeli brother-in-law.
Right?
Right,
right.
Well,
this is the great irony when you don't understand,
um,
history and,
and,
and you also see everything through the prism of your own misunderstood,
um,
or your,
when you understand everything or you see everything through the prism of your
very small American Lens.
Meaning these people grew up in America and they know that America's,
um,
problems have historically been between black and white people,
for example,
until they think that everywhere else in the world,
all of the conflicts that are going on are obviously also can something to be
divided along those racial lines.
It's ironically jingoistic on some level,
um,
or imperialistic to use there to use their terms to see everything through the
Lens Lens and through the vantage point of your own reality,
uh,
or historic reality,
which is what they're projecting onto their understanding of Israel,
Israeli society.
Not Knowing,
for example,
that the majority of Jews in Israel are people of color,
not knowing,
just to really get down to details that Likud party,
which is baby's party,
um,
rose to power because of its,
uh,
taking on the challenges and the,
and the,
um,
and the interests of the Ms Community is road.
The Jews from,
from,
from North Africa right there.
There is no,
like there is no understanding of this reality because this reality can not
possibly exist with him and intersection list view of society.
Yeah.
So in that way it becomes the perfect test case for there.
I would say basic struggle for what reality is in a way or something like that.
Well,
struggle,
reality,
inability again to deal with depth.
Like I think that that's what this boils down to.
Ultimate ultimately inability to deal with nuance and inability to do with
humor,
to deal with human complexity,
the very complexity that they themselves have and possess.
Um,
and that's a skillset to be able to do that.
Right.
That's a virtue I think to be able to do that.
And so it's not just the fact that these to go back to students are promoting,
which is toxic and bad.
It's also bad for them,
right?
Like they're not going to have a healthy holistic life if they are unable to
deal with depth and human complexity.
Do you think it is also something I'm not totally sure about this but saying to
do is just the geographic size of Israel,
like the absurdly tiny nature of the borders that you could literally drive both
ways up north,
south,
east,
west,
easily in a day.
You could drive all the way north all the way back,
I'm sure in one day.
Yeah.
I think it's about six hour drive up north down south.
This way you could drive like,
I dunno,
15 times in a day or something like that,
but that it's so small that they're focused on that can become like even more of
a laser even though they make it seem like it's just this my monstrous ever
growing,
um,
blob or something like that.
I mean,
I don't know.
Honestly,
I haven't quite figured out the geographical piece to this.
I don't know if it's relevant in their level of analysis.
I think right.
That's probably,
it's probably a little too high level or something.
I don't think that really crosses their mind.
Um,
I think that,
I think just once you see the world through caricature and once you see,
see yourself as living in this space where everyone's against you,
um,
then it's easy to fall into this trap of either antisemitism or being very early
clue,
coming in very early,
close to antisemitism.
So what are some of the things that people say about you as you have fought this
battle?
Because,
uh,
you know,
look,
I can look at some of my,
uh,
some of my other friends and former guests that are black that I've taken
unpopular positions related to the way black people are supposed to things,
which is of course inherently racist,
but the things that is awesome.
Right?
Exactly.
Yeah.
So the things that get said about Larry Elder,
let's say you were tying to solve for the last 50 years or,
or my friend David Webb,
plenty of other people.
Um,
I know you get a certain percentage of that is when I was doing a little Google
and idea people,
people say not nice things.
Yeah.
I mean it could be that I just turned off my Twitter mentions and so I don't
know,
figured out the meaning of life.
I don't really like come on,
it's a contact with,
I mean honestly I,
if it is happening,
I think I have a filter and it is happening.
Right.
But I think I have a feel too,
I feel too is put in place and turned on that limit my seeing them,
I hate to sound like callous,
but I just don't care.
Meaning I think,
I think that under use used to let me,
like in college,
like someone was very pejorative toward and someone was very racist toward me
because of my,
my like calling me like a slave and all of these various things.
Um,
and there have been other,
like I had a death threat.
I suspect this was a tolerant left Dee saying that because of your views.
Right.
You know what,
I don't want to caricature Dave according to what I'm talking about.
Good Person Am I think I'm right.
Sure.
Yeah.
I'm just saying I don't want to caricature the left as this sort.
Like
I know mom,
but that's what we call an educated guess.
That's fair.
Yes.
He himself particularly,
yeah.
Happened to belong to it.
Yes.
Um,
but,
but what was I gonna say?
Oh,
I had a death threat and also in college,
which was,
it wasn't funny,
but I dunno,
it's kind of funny that someone would take such time to like focus his energy on
me,
um,
which is a little weird.
But beside that,
um,
I,
I just spend my time and my energy just trying to put out good things into the
world.
And I think that because I focus on that more than what the haters to the
speaker saying,
I just don't notice them anymore.
And I'm just trying to put good energy out into the world.
To that end.
You wrote your first piece in the New York Times.
How long ago?
About five,
six months ago.
Something like that.
Not that,
something like that.
Yeah.
I think in July or something.
Why I refuse was it,
why refuse to hate white people?
Why I want to get this right?
I'm sorry.
Why I refuse to avoid white people.
I'm pretty sure you're supposed to remember this.
I don't see your first New York Times.
Oh,
right.
They get the title.
What do you make of that title then let's,
let's start that way.
Cause,
but a lot of people don't know that that often you can write an op Ed for a
major paper and that you don't pick the title because often people don't get
past the title.
Right,
right.
I mean,
I didn't have a problem with it.
I think it was true to the essence of what I was saying.
So what was happening that I suspect it has a lot to do with everything we've
talked about here,
but what,
what was going on that you thought that you had to write this?
I mean this,
this should be pretty obvious stuff.
Actual pieces in the New York Times where other people,
people of color were saying like,
I'm not going to have my child speak to white people.
And I was like,
what
there,
there was one,
I mean,
you're not making this up.
There was one just a little bit before that that literally was saying,
yeah,
literally said that.
I think that I was also,
I was also having this intellectual fight within myself against Ta-nehisi coats
and sort of everything he stands for and like I have a very strong reaction to
that.
And I think that this piece was the product of all of those things and a
response to all of those things.
Um,
and the gist of it was just that I grew up around all types of people,
white people,
black people,
Muslims,
Asians.
Like I went to a very egalitarian high school,
extremely got Sarian.
So,
um,
so the process by which people again caricature,
caricature each other and caricature white people is something that is a very
foreign thing to me.
Like,
I don't,
I can't quite wrap my head around that sort of language that's used,
um,
by people who believe in intersectionality and quite frankly by people who
probably have good intent.
Like I'm sure the guy who wrote that piece about having his child,
of what white people was coming from,
a place of genuine,
sincere place of concern.
Um,
so I don't want to like disparate him in any way,
but I just don't think
you would say his answers are confused.
Yeah,
yeah,
exactly.
Um,
but,
but I would,
I would say that his fear was probably real.
Right.
And so,
um,
I think that there's just a better way in a more healthier way of going about
these things.
Yeah.
What do you think a Martin Luther King would think about our society right now?
There's a good one.
[inaudible] my tweet yesterday
I saw your tweet.
Tell the good people
I said I was preparing for taping and I was doing so by watching Dr King's
speeches.
And that's so funny.
Well,
you're good at your job.
No,
I'm alright.
I'm all right.
Well,
what do you,
what do you think he would think of things these days?
The state of the way we,
we talk about race,
the people that I think think they're his natural allies are often using
arguments that are what I would say or 180 degrees.
The reverse of what his arguments were.
Yeah.
Dr. King,
I know this is almost an impossible question.
Okay.
Yeah.
So I mean,
Dr. King wrote a book called strength to love.
What is the collection of his sermons?
Um,
and I think in one of the first or second like sermons slash SAS,
he talks about like why he routed his nonviolent movement in this belief in
concept of love or God pay Love,
love,
love for love's sake,
essentially.
Um,
and I think that given the fact that,
that he wrote that he wrote that,
I think that he would definitely issue this new impulse within society to reduce
each other to immutable characteristics.
I mean,
this is what he was fighting against,
right?
But,
or I should say and write,
he would also have devised a rhetoric that was strong enough and compelling
enough to inspire people to aspire to loving each other.
And I think that's,
that's actually what's missing.
Um,
aside from a few different commentators here in there who might be,
who sort of exists in the,
I think the Ted talk circuit.
Um,
I don't think that there's this movement with an America trying to teach people
how to love.
And I think that that's something we've lost.
And that was something that was very central to Dr King's writings of Dr King's
work.
Again,
as I said earlier,
to devise a blueprint where you say,
I am not going to fight back against this white person.
Not just because nonviolence is a very strategic tactic,
but because this man was made in the image of God,
like that is existential and there is no profoundly,
um,
existential movement rooted in love in the same way that it was a,
when he devised it in the 60s.
Is that partly because we've just made everything political?
Yes,
yes.
Uh,
I mean the,
it's become like our identity,
right?
Which is,
by the way,
it why I'm just like,
when you say like the left than the right,
like I don't know these,
these categories to have to a certain extent lost meaning for me
and I,
I would say that all the time.
And I think you can,
even when I'm saying them,
there's a certain exhaustion,
right?
Sometimes you just have to frame that you,
we just need words.
You know?
It's funny you said,
yeah,
we've sort of lost the language to talk about some of this stuff.
Okay.
So lives,
you just need some labels loosely to talk about these things.
Otherwise,
the people who can handle complexity and the people who cannot,
I'll go with that.
But can you give me something snappy or can we get words to make out a little
snappier and you get that in one bumper sticker,
but that,
that really is what it is.
I mean,
that also explains the explosion of these conversations online,
right?
Because we're not getting them through the mainstream media.
I would say friends and potential friends.
Okay.
I told you we were going to end this with love.
Do you have anything else in the love department?
I think you nailed it there.
And then I want to talk about your website real quick.
Oh,
I was going to talk about that,
but yeah.
Oh,
all right.
So then let's roll.
Let's roll them together right into that.
Yeah.
Okay.
So one of the reasons why,
um,
there are negative conversations being had about various topics,
various political topics on college campuses and even in our political discourse
in general,
um,
is because of the framework in which that conversation is had the framework,
we've talked about it as intersectionality to a certain extent.
Um,
intersectionality essentially encourages people to make assumptions about each
other,
whether it's assumptions based upon skin color,
based upon financial status or lack thereof based upon gender,
et Cetera.
So in order to challenge the conversation or change the conversation,
you have to challenge the framework and the framework,
the challenges.
Intersectionality is the theory of in champ.
And somebody here has a website called theory of enchantment.com.
What the hell is going on over there?
So a little bit of context.
I was at the Wall Street Journal for a year,
2015.
I was mentored by Bret Stephens and part of my assignment was to develop a
paper.
Uh,
and in this paper I was essentially trying to figure out what the psychology of
connection was.
What,
why do people gravitate toward with what they gravitate toward.
And if I can figure out the psychology of connection or the science of
connection and can I use that science of connection to heal disconnection.
And that is what ended up being the theory of enchantment and the theory of
enchantment.
Um,
draw drives or um,
depends heavily upon pop culture,
studying pop culture because pop culture shows us what we gravitate toward.
Um,
so I began to ask myself questions during the course of writing this research
paper.
Like why do we gravitate to are companies like Nike?
What is it?
What is it you love Nike.
I love Nike.
But like for some people Nike as a religion,
like it's like on that level and like,
why do we gravitate towards singer songwriters and influencers like Beyonce?
And people would say,
well,
it's Beyonce.
It's very obvious quotes.
But I'm like,
no,
it's not sign off.
Yes,
there's something happening now.
And it turns out that all of these influencers and always these companies,
et Cetera,
are doing one simple thing.
They're creating content where the audience sees themselves and their potential
reflecting on the content and that's how they're generating connection.
So you wear that Nike shoe because you think to yourself,
I wear this Nike Shoe,
I'll be able to just do it right is this little one goes.
Um,
when Beyonce says who run the world,
girls,
women see themselves and their potential reflected in that song.
So they gravitate to where her.
So how do we use that basic idea to bring together people who have been
disconnected?
Um,
so the theory even Shama has three rules,
three principles of trying to bring connection in previously polarized spaces.
And this can be used in interpersonal conflict or conflicts of other nature's.
So the first rule is to remember that we are human beings and not political
abstractions.
Cause the first thing that happens in these spaces,
we have these,
we abstract about each other.
We think that we're talking to political objects or entities and on a per a full
person.
And what I will do in a presentation is I will point to a pop culture reference
that illustrates this.
And I'm usually point to Kendrick Lamar because Kendrick Lamar has a song called
DNA and he says in the song I got power,
poison and pain and joy inside my DNA.
And what he's doing when he says that is he is articulating an illustrating what
it means to be a human being.
We have all of these things within us,
we have the capacity to do good,
we have the capacity to destroy,
have the capacity to build up right?
And we have the capacity to tear down.
And just as this,
this impulse exists within the person.
While I disagree with I'm having a problem with,
it also exists within me.
Right?
And realizing this is sort of the beginning I think for empathy and mutual
understanding.
So that's the first rule.
Remember we are human beings,
not political abstractions.
And as a corollary,
we will knock,
dehumanize,
or stereotype or objectify any of the human beings or any of the communities
involved in this conflict,
whatever that conflict is.
The second principle is if you want to criticize,
criticize,
in order to uplift and empower,
never to tear down,
never to destroy.
So if that person who believes in him,
intersectionality is being very mean to me and aggressive to me,
um,
I could criticize him by cursing him out,
right?
And,
but by,
you know,
speaking down to him,
or I can criticize him in a way that makes it very clear that I actually believe
in his potential and actually believe that he's better than the content or the
rhetoric,
the empty rhetoric that he's putting out.
And by speaking in the manner that suggests that I'm more likely to change him.
So a quick story.
My Angelo told this story about how she,
uh,
she was on set with Tupac at a movie set and Tupac was in the corner somewhere,
cursing out this guy,
uh,
who he didn't like and they were like about to get into a fight.
And then Maya Angelo says,
come here,
let me talk to you.
And he's two POCs.
So he's like,
here,
he's like still mumbling under his breath.
And then she says,
come over here,
let me talk to you.
And then she tells him,
don't you know that we are counting on you.
Don't you know that you were the next generation and,
and that we're looking toward you to pave the way for us.
Don't you know that you have been loved and we're looking towards you as the
next,
as the next person to uphold us.
And so the story goes that in that moment,
Tupac starts crying because she had rooted her criticism and her fundamental
belief in him,
you know?
And then the next day he's like,
he's sort of like kind of still being aggressive toward that guy.
And then Maya Maya passes and he goes,
he likes up.
He goes,
good morning,
Miss Angelo.
Right?
So he changed it.
He modified his behavior in front of someone because she believes in him.
Um,
so that's the second.
And then the third principle,
the third and final principle is everything we do,
we try to route and love and compassion.
What sounds,
what sounds very like,
you know,
fake.
But what it means is if someone is being aggressive towards you or mean towards
you or whatever,
you call that out as inappropriate to say,
you know,
I don't know you from Adam.
I don't know why you're prejudging me,
which is the definition of prejudice,
right on board I'm not going to do is I'm not going to prejudge you even though
you have prejudged me.
I'm instead if you want,
let's go to this coffee shop and let's actually talk about this topic to topic x
topic.
Why whenever we're having a disagreement over,
because what's happening in that moment is they're probably seen you as a
political distraction,
none as a full human being and you have to rehumanize that space and you end up,
the purpose by the way,
is not to get that person to agree with every single viewpoint you have the
Ppar.
The purpose of that is to bring back compassionate empathy even in the midst of
profound disagreement.
What do something weird,
we are not doing so well here,
uh,
in America.
So that's the theory.
Even chairman,
it's been a pleasure.
Can you run for president or something?
Yeah,
absolutely not.
That would not work with any of those three pillars.
No,
no,
it would,
I just,
I prefer a pop culture to a political culture.
Yeah,
that's,
that's the honest truth,
but I appreciate that.
Yeah.
All right.
Well,
I'm so glad we finally did this and we'll do it again for sure.
And for more on Chloe,
you can check out the theory of enchantment Daca.